Successful negotiation is not about
winning. It's about building long-term
relationships. My name is Matt Abrahams.
I teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast, Talk Smart, the
podcast.
>> [music]
>> Today I look forward to speaking with my
friend Stan Christensen. Stan is a
professional negotiator who has both
practiced and taught negotiation for his
entire career. And he teaches a very
popular Stanford negotiation course.
Additionally, Stan is the host of the
very informative All Things Negotiation
podcast. Well, welcome Stan. I
thoroughly enjoyed being on your show
and I'm glad you're here. Thanks for
being here.
>> Thanks for inviting me.
>> Excellent. Shall we get started?
>> We should do it.
>> All right. If you think about it, we're
always negotiating. Sometimes formally
and many times informally. How do you
define negotiation and and what makes
for success in a negotiation?
>> It's a great question. I define
negotiation as any attempt to persuade
or influence another party, which is
very broad. In terms of the second part
of your question, how do you define
success? Most people think of
negotiation statically. It's you and I,
there's a fixed pie, we're trying to get
more for ourselves and less for the
other party. But in reality, probably
95% of the negotiations you're going to
do are going to be with people you see
again. So I define success as
are you contributing to the value of the
long-term relationship?
>> Yeah. And and I think that's really
important because you can do some things
to better your position in a negotiation
that might not be bettering your first
your future interaction with the person.
And so we really need to be thinking
about not just what's happening in the
moment, but it's consequences. I think
about as I was raising my kids, there
were lots of things that I chose not to
really negotiate because I knew we would
have future conversations. So I think
that's an important way to look at
negotiation. Like me, you teach Stanford
students and and your students really
enjoy your class. What are two or three
key things you hope your students take
away from your content on negotiation?
>> Yeah, the first thing is just awareness
that they're negotiating all the time.
So, the very first week of class, I have
them keep track of the negotiations that
they engage in throughout the week.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> And it's probably a hundred if they're
honest about it. And so, number one is
the awareness. Number two, I try to help
them be effective negotiating in the
context they're most likely to negotiate
in. Those tend to be roommates, uh
romantic partners, um employers,
potential employers, parents. And so, if
they come away from the class more
confident that they can do those things,
that's a success for me.
>> So, it sounds like awareness and
confidence in the ability to do it. And
I like that idea of reflecting, you
know, we we we communicate all the time,
not all communication is negotiation,
although much of it is. Taking the time
to say, you know, what am I doing? What
do they look like? And And maybe some of
your students identify patterns and you
can help them better understand what's
working and what's not working.
>> Yeah.
>> I know one of the things you teach,
which which I believe personally is
really important in all communication,
but you you teach listening.
Why is listening part of negotiation
curriculum? And can you share some of
the best practices you teach your
students about listening and how it
applies to negotiation?
>> Yeah, listening is more than a
nice-to-have. It's essential. One of the
things that I say about listening is you
need to think about what you're
listening for in the negotiation. And
so, think about questions you might have
that might elicit things that make you
question some of your assumptions. I'll
give you a recent example. I was
visiting a family friend in a retirement
community, and the family wanted to move
her from the first floor to the second
floor. She was resisting tremendously.
Um they assumed she didn't like the
smaller room. They assumed she didn't
like the stairs. It was really a lot of
bickering, and they came in and said,
"Stan, you know, you're a good friend of
the family. Can you help us with this
situation?" And um when I asked her,
"What are the real reasons that you're
afraid to move?" She said, "I'm worried
that I'm going to lose my nurse because
she's the nurse on the first floor and I
don't want to change nurses. And so I
simply said to the director of the
facility, what if we had that nurse stay
with her and have the nurse travel
rather than her get someone new? And
they said that'd be fine and she said
that'd be fine and so we solved the
problem. And that was based on listening
to her real concerns.
>> What I find so interesting about what
you just said is listening is equipping
you to ask the right questions.
>> Right.
>> And I don't often think of negotiation
as question asking. I think of it as
asserting.
Talk to me about how questioning
inquiry, uh, thinking about the other
person plays out when you're
negotiating.
>> Well, you know, we have classes in
public speaking.
>> Yes.
>> What we probably should do is have a
class in public listening.
>> Agreed.
>> Because listening is probably should be
more than half of the conversation. If
you listen, it's not just to be a moral
person or be a friendly person, it's
because it's going to equip you to come
up with solutions that expand the pie as
we talked about before. And so it's a
persuasive element to listen as opposed
to a nice-to-have.
>> I really think that's important for
everybody to think about when it comes
to negotiation. You know, I I I tend to
look at negotiation as
uh, something where I want to win or
have my point of view uh, dominate in
that conversation. And what I'm hearing
you say is
before you negotiate, you actually have
to listen and then ask questions to best
understand what's important. In the
example you gave, uh, I wouldn't have
thought that the thing that was
preventing that move was was something
external to the the person who was
having to be moved, but it was. And so
by asking the questions, I guess it
helps you focus in on where you have
that negotiation.
>> Yeah, a lot of my students um, show up
to my class hoping they're going to
learn how to win.
>> Yeah.
>> And a lot of them sign up because it's
called negotiation and that sounds sexy.
What I teach them is relationship
management. Now, if I called the class
not negotiation but relationship
management, I think I'd get a lot fewer
kids uh, signing up. So I use a little
bit of a smoke screen there and teach
relationship management.
>> Yeah, well, I it but one of the big ways
we we manage relationships is through
the negotiation, the influence that we
have. But you have to really understand
who you're talking to and what's
important to them.
Um I often, you know, my wife and I will
often have negotiations
when in fact we probably didn't need to
because we didn't appreciate each
other's perspective. The example I
always give is, you know, if we want to
go out to dinner and she says, "Hey,
let's go out to Mexican food." And I
say, "No, let's do Italian food." That
could be a negotiation. But when we ask
each other, "How important is it?"
You know, for me it's not that important
and for her it's very important, then we
don't have to and that helps us manage
our relationship. So I like this idea of
listening and inquiry.
But it does bring up the the question
though.
Often in negotiation emotion plays out.
Uh
you you're very passionate about the
topic you're advocating for or you might
get angry because somebody isn't going
along. How do you deal with emotion in
these kind of situations?
>> Yeah, it's a great and common question.
Uh the first piece is to be aware of
your emotions. We could do a whole
podcast on that. Let's just take one of
the examples you brought up, anger.
Um have you ever been in an argument
with your wife
towards the end of the day where you
might be going to bed angry but you
still try to work it out? Has that ever
happened to you in your marriage?
>> I wish I could say no, but it yes, it
does happen a lot. [laughter]
>> And one of the pieces of advice you
hear, I heard before I got married, is
never go to bed angry.
>> Right.
>> You couldn't give people worse marital
advice. Um often the best thing to do if
you're feeling angry is to pause. And
so, you know, when cooler heads prevail,
maybe the next morning after a good
night's sleep. And so when you're
feeling uh emotionally hijacked, maybe a
little bit out of control, the
sophisticated negotiator hits the pause
button and returns when cooler heads can
prevail.
>> So I think it's first recognizing the
emotion and then take giving yourself
permission to take that pause and and
and find perhaps an outlet, write it
down, talk to somebody about it, and
then come back to it.
Does Does emotion though play a role? I
can imagine that that if I bring a level
of intensity, passion, it it could help
me actually show that this is important
to me.
>> Yeah, you don't want to think about
emotion tactically. What you want to do
is be as genuine and be yourself.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay? Cuz people that use tactics and
try to act like they're upset when
they're not upset, um we tend not to be
very good at lying about our emotions.
Right. And so what I think you want to
do is be emotionally centered. What I
often recommend to people is before you
enter a important negotiation, go and
just wherever the quiet place is for you
and pause and think about what am I
feeling? What am I bringing? Do I need
to shift gears in my emotion? Um way too
many people try to plow through negative
emotions, whether they're hurt or sad or
angry or feeling melancholy. Um they
just approach it and and try to drive
in. It's just like if you'd had too much
to drink, you probably shouldn't jump in
that car and drive. You shouldn't uh be
an emotional drunk driver in
negotiation.
>> I like that. Yeah, yeah. It That That's
a really uh appropriate metaphor that I
think can really help us remind
ourselves that
em- emotion we need we need to be
centered and if we are in a place that's
not going to lead to the the not just
the negotiation, but the future
relationship that we the way we want it
to, we need to address it.
I am curious about
how we show up in terms of our presence,
what we do with our body and our voice.
Does this have implications for
negotiation, how you how you physically
show up?
>> It absolutely does. Um a modern topic
related to this is distant negotiations,
whether it's Zoom or Google Meet. And I
always recommend to people if at all
possible, meet live and in person.
Because those nuances of body language,
and not only that, it's much easier to
create small talk um if you're live in
person. I find that when I'm on a Zoom
meeting or any kind of negotiation, it's
get down to the business. And so we miss
the subtleties, we miss the nuance.
>> I've heard across several of your
answers this notion of connection before
you do the negotiation.
Connect with yourself, your emotions,
where are you? Help regulate that, but
then connect with others.
Given that in a negotiation, you're
trying to assert a particular point of
view or position,
how how do you balance, you know, hey,
I'm a nice person. I want you to like
me. I want this relationship to
continue, but I also need this to get
done or want this to get done or see
this is the right way of doing things.
I I agree connection is important, but
but how do you thread that needle?
That's a tough thing, I would think.
>> Let's tie back to your comments about
listening.
>> Yeah.
>> If I come to a negotiation with some
questions that might change some of the
assumptions I came with, I might want to
assert or problem solve or create
options that are different than the
thing I came with. And so in every
negotiation, you are my teacher. And I
can learn things that help us both work
together to expand the pie, rather than
advocating. The reason that attorneys
often aren't very good at negotiation,
and I don't want to over generalize,
what are attorneys trained to doing
mostly?
>> They're to assert a point of view and
win the argument.
>> They're advocates for their clients. How
good are attorneys at joint problem
solving? They let's roll up our sleeves,
let's creative, let's figure out a
structure that works for both sides and
rewards the long-term relationship,
which is again our goal. Attorneys
aren't very good at that.
>> Yeah.
>> Right? And so I often kick the attorneys
out of the room if it's an important
negotiation.
>> Interesting. I'm sure they love that.
>> I [laughter] think they get paid they
get paid either way.
>> Okay. Okay. Um you said something there
that I that I that I I want to double
down on. Uh we had Michelle Gelfand on.
Michelle teaches at the business school
with me. She likes to talk about this
notion of minding your metaphors. And
the metaphor you approach any
communicative act frames how you do it.
So if I see a negotiation as a battle,
I'm going to approach it very
differently than the metaphor you used,
which I really liked, is the person
you're negotiating with or the people
you're negotiating with are your
teachers. And if they're your teachers,
that means one, you're both working to
learn, they're to teach and you to
learn, and that there's a collaboration
that's in inherent in that. And I really
like that approach.
Inherent in that, part of that then, is
the questions that we bring and and ask.
So, I'm wondering
have you found in your own experience
and do you teach
I can imagine how I frame the position
that I have or the even the issue we're
negotiating really matters. If I frame
it as a question, is that different than
framing it as an assertion? So, let's
think of an example of framing. Let's
say that I come to you, Madam. We've had
some tension in our relationship and I
say, "Matt, I'd like to bring up
something very difficult with you
today." How's that make you feel?
>> I I'm concerned. I'm taken aback.
>> Right, you're defensive. Exactly. And
that's 99% of people. Now, let's just
change the frame a little bit. Matt, um
look, there's something I've been
meaning to bring up with you. I've had a
hard time bringing it up. I've sought
counsel from some of my friends on how
to do it and I'm feeling ambivalent
about doing it, but we're both um
teachers of communication and so I'd
like to try to do that, but I want you
to kind of work with me on it. Would now
be a good time to do that or should we
just set up a formal meeting? How do you
feel now?
>> Well, one, I'm curious and two, much
more willing to roll up my sleeves and
and work with you on it. So, so the way
you framed that, the position you came
from, does make a huge difference.
>> Yeah, and so what you want to do with
someone is make them feel comfortable.
One of the greatest things I encounter
when I negotiate is people look at my
background on LinkedIn and they're like,
"Oh my gosh, professional negotiator. He
used to do things like negotiate with
hostages. What's he going to do to me?"
Versus I come to them thinking, "I want
to joint problem solve. I want to figure
out how to build the relationship over
time." And so I have kind of have to put
them at ease and that's one of the key
skills in negotiation.
>> Yeah, so that that small talk, that
connection really does make a difference
in addition to the framing.
>> Are there things that we can do in
advance to the negotiation to help? I'm
a big fan of setting expectations,
helping people understand what's going
to unfold.
Can we do things in advance and and can
you give us an example or two? So for
I'll I'll share with you sort of the
thing I'm fishing for. When I run
meetings, I will make sure in my meeting
invite I'm very specific about what we
we can expect, how we're going to go
through it. So when people show up,
they're not surprised. Are there things
that we can do like that to help with
negotiation?
>> Well, let's just take your example of
having an agenda. So I always do the
same thing.
>> Okay.
>> Um I always start with an agenda.
Now, people can feel that you're being
controlling if it's your agenda. Let's
say it's a two-party negotiation. So
what I always say is I've come with some
thoughts and a draft agenda. We can
either use that or we can use an agenda
that you have or we can create one
together on the whiteboard. What would
be your preference?
>> Right.
>> Okay? How often do my counterparts say,
"Yeah, I also came with an agenda and
I'd rather use mine." How often does
that
>> They really don't.
>> It's never happened in my whole career.
So that gives you a lot of power in a
negotiation. You're going to control the
agenda. And so what should go on the
agenda? You should think about what are
the objectives, okay? What people should
be there? What's kind of a process for
communication? Is this a one-time
meeting? Are we clear about the
outcomes?
And then I would go into some of the
things that I wanted either communicate
or to learn in the meeting then we have
other frameworks that we can talk about.
But I love your point on agendas.
>> And I I really like the offer to
co-create an agenda.
Even if they don't take you up on it, it
shows that you are willing to be
collaborative, listen, and work together
to define it. And and I think that
positions that connection and and
a respect that really only serves you
benefit in that.
>> And the other thing I'll do to even go
the next step is I will maybe put my
chair on their side of the table, share
the agenda, or put it up on a whiteboard
so that it's we're kind of co-creating
it. There's a famous saying in
negotiation that the art of negotiation
is letting them have your way. Now, it
feels a little manipulative, [laughter]
but on agenda, having them feel like a
co-creator of that agenda makes all the
difference in the world.
>> I like that. Let them feel like they're
having your way. That's That's great.
You said something there that I really
want to highlight that that you can
actually manage not only the agenda, but
the physical setup of the room. I
remember when I was learning to be a
high school teacher. I taught high
school for 2 years when I left high-tech
before I started the career I have
today. I taught high school and they
taught us classroom management. And one
of the things they said is when you are
sitting down with a student who has done
something inappropriate, wrong,
challenging,
think about how you set your chair to
face their chair. Is it shoulders facing
each other or do you sit the chairs
askew so you're not directly and it
makes a tremendous difference. So, I
really like you highlighting
where you put yourself in the room.
>> Yeah.
>> Where the orientation is towards
whatever the shared experience, the
whiteboard, etc. Thank you for bringing
that up. That makes a big difference.
>> Yeah.
>> And most of us don't think about that at
all. We just come sit wherever we can.
>> Yeah, I think just put that under the
category of setup. You want to have a
setup that works for both sides.
>> Before we switch topics to talk about a
few other things, is can you share one
mistake many people make when they go to
negotiate that that does a disservice to
them? And is there one thing beyond
listening and some of the other things
you've talked about that you wish
everybody was doing that would really
help them in negotiation?
>> The biggest mistake I see people make is
to get hijacked by a surprise. Okay?
Often something will come up that you
weren't expecting. All that means is
that some assumption you were making is
coming into question. So, what they
should do is then start inquiring and
drilling down. What was I missing? How
do I get to this assumption I made that
was in fact incorrect? And so, that's a
mistake a lot of people make.
>> I like that. So, the mistake and the
correction there. So, if something goes
awry or doesn't go the way you expected,
rather than entrench yourself or or get
distant, lean in and ask questions.
Really helpful. You host an amazing
podcast. You were very kind to have me
on as a guest. It's called All Things
Negotiation. I've learned a lot from it.
Uh why did you choose to do a podcast
and what do you hope to accomplish with
it? So, we'll edit that one in. So,
let's imagine I said, "What's What's one
story that you've learned from that
really how you negotiate?"
>> Yeah, it's a great question. Really two
things. I'm passionate about teaching
negotiation as you as you mentioned. We
teach here at Stanford. That's a very
small elite group of students. And so,
my podcast is an effort to get the word
out of how to negotiate to a broader
audience. So, how do you learn
negotiation?
The best way you can learn is by hearing
people's stories. So, I interviewed
people who are experienced. They might
be, you know, working in the startup
world. They might be working in
government. They might be working in the
world of sports. I've even had athletes
on there. And so, it's sharing people's
stories about negotiation to create
learning.
That's that's really the most important
thing. The second reason is it's fun.
You and I met each other because of my
podcast. And so, I'm constantly meeting
new people and, you know,
improving the things that I teach my
students. One of the things I really
value about how you do your podcast is
you solicit a lot of stories from your
guests. Is there a story that you
learned that had a change or impact on
the way you communicate and negotiate?
>> I do think I've learned from all of my
guests, including you, of course. The
one that jumps to mind is General
Stanley McChrystal. I was fortunate to
interview him.
And I've been thinking about the
interview ever since. And the reason
I've been thinking about it is he
recently wrote a book called On
Character. He talks about how character
is in fact a negotiation. And it's a
lifetime of negotiating your character,
the ability to trust one another's, more
importantly, to be trustworthy. And if
we we at kind of our country and what's
going on right now, we need more people
that have developed relationships of
trust and character. And he's not only a
great example of that, but in the
interview he teaches us how to do that.
>> I love that you learned from somebody
who's a great teacher. I've had the good
fortune to interview him as well. Thank
you. You helped make that happen. But
also that that point about trust and and
building trust so important. This has
been a great conversation as I knew it
would. Before we end, I'd like to ask
everybody three questions. One I'm going
to make up for you and the other two
I've been asking across all the podcast
episodes. Are you up for that?
>> Absolutely.
>> Excellent.
>> Beyond the negotiating you do and the
teaching that you do of negotiation,
you've navigated the venture capital
world. You've raised money. You've
helped people raise money. What's your
best advice for communicating a new
disruptive idea to those who might be
skeptical or unsure of what you're
saying?
>> Yeah, the most important advice here is
to present as they want to be presented
to. Most venture capitalists either have
a video or a blog or something online
talking about how they like
presentations to go. So if you come with
that information, hey, I did some
research on on your firm and you guys
tend to like to use PowerPoint or you
guys tend to just like to do Q&A. And I
would start by saying, hey, I've done
some research. I assume that what you
guys really like to do is Q&A. Should we
jump right to that or I have a
PowerPoint we can use that. So you're
kind of asking for permission and then
they feel like wow, you're
sophisticated. The second thing about
venture capitalist is they're a little
bit like car dealers in the sense that
they know what they're doing. If you try
to play their game, they're going to
win. They're going to play it better.
And so what I say is rather than try to
play their game better, create the terms
for the game. And I tell the students
create a two-week period that you're
willing to talk to venture capitalist.
Define that so that they don't drag it
out for 4 months and introduce you
individually to their partners over a
long period of time. And it creates a
little bit of a scarcity mentality. So
don't try to play their game, play your
game cuz you're not going to play their
game better.
>> So, the very first thing I heard you say
is take time to reflect on your audience
and and many of these folks will tell
you how they want to be communicated
with. So,
appreciate that and then act
accordingly. And then the other thing
that's implied in that is you have to
adjust and adapt your message. A lot of
people I know who I help with pitching
just create one pitch and they just keep
delivering it in different circumstances
and what you're advising is no, you have
to adjust and adapt to what they tell
you. And then the second part of your
advice is
set up parameters. You can bring your
own parameters and boundaries to the
interaction and and that can be helpful
because it can it can build momentum
more quickly.
I'll be curious to hear your answer to
question number two. Who is a
communicator that you admire and why?
>> One that comes to mind is Dr. Martin
Luther King.
>> Sure.
>> And the why is he was able to fuse
beautiful, vivid storytelling with moral
authority in a way that I don't know
anyone else who has done that. Um for my
students, I have them read the letter
from Birmingham jail every semester and
we look at that as a persuasive
document. It's a in effect a
negotiation.
And so, what Martin Luther King was able
to do by both the written and spoken
word word for me puts him in the Hall of
Fame. No one touches him. He essentially
appealed to our consciousness and if you
can appeal to someone's consciousness
and change a generation, he
fast-forwarded how we manage and we're
still negotiating race relations.
But he did more to change how we think
about that than any other person and so,
I think he's my top choice.
>> I really love that you use one of his
speeches as an example of negotiation.
I have used several of his speeches as
examples of lots of things, rhetorical
flourish, uh clarity, engagement, but
I've never used it as a negotiation and
I think that's really fascinating. Thank
you for sharing that and thank you for
doing that with our students.
Final question. What are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe?
>> Well, I'm not much of a cook, but um
>> [laughter]
>> I have a lot to say about negotiation. I
would say the first one that comes to
mind is vulnerability.
>> Oh.
>> We assume that we should come in very
strong, very powerful, to use your word
advocate. When in reality, if you can be
vulnerable, it tends to beget
vulnerability on the other side. So,
that would be my first ingredient.
Um
second would be to question your
assumptions. And let's just drill into
that a little bit more than we did
earlier. We all come with assumptions. I
come with certain assumptions to this
conversation. We're both white males, we
both teach at Stanford, we're both
middle-aged, we have kids, a lot of
similarities. But there probably some
things that we really see differently.
And flushing that out. And so, question
the assumption that you understand the
other party, that you know what they
want. And as we talked about earlier,
that there's nothing they could tell you
that wouldn't change your objectives for
what a successful outcome would be in
the negotiations. That would be second
is questioning your assumptions.
I'd say third, have an action plan for
going forward. Um often people negotiate
very complex agreements and they go file
that, you know, in the digital file
somewhere. And what gets implemented is
totally different. In the world that I
used to work in, mergers and
acquisitions, often they don't work out
very well. And the reason is no one is
focused on the implementation. So, it
doesn't matter how effective you are at
negotiation if the deal doesn't get
implemented effectively. So, that'd be
my third ingredient.
>> I really like that you started answering
this question with vulnerability. And
when I think about negotiation, I I
vulnerability is the antithesis of what
I think about. But I can really see
based on what you've shared, not just in
this answer, but prior, how that really
sets you up to to have an
a relationship
that sets the negotiation on a path to
success.
Questioning assumptions, absolutely
understand why that's important. We come
in uh perhaps more rigid than we should,
and staying open, and then having a
clear action plan for what comes next.
Really important. Great recipe. Even
though you say you're not a good cook, I
can certainly see that you're going to
set up a great negotiation. You've laid
out what's important for successful
negotiation and more importantly
successful relationships. And really
negotiation is but one tool for managing
those relationships. And thank you for
challenging us to see negotiation more
broadly and providing us with the tools
and techniques to do it better. Thank
you.
>> Nice to be here.
>> [music]